[Musik]
>> SALLY: Hallo!
Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt!
Heute gibt es ein leckeres Ramadan-Dessert!
Zum Ramadan gibt es ja oft diese traditionellen
– ich sage jetzt nicht türkischen,
denn Ramadan ist ja nicht nur türkisch,
sondern international.
Diese traditionellen Desserts wie zum Beispiel Baklava
oder Tulumba tatlısı, also frittiertes Spritzgebäck.
Und ich habe mir jetzt gedacht,
was natürlich auch ganz typisch ist, finde ich,
sind Datteln, Walnüsse,
Zimt, Orangenblütenwasser
oder Rosenwasser.
Und ich habe mir jetzt ein Dessert überlegt,
was einfach zu machen ist,
aber auch leicht schmeckt,
also nicht ganz so süß, nicht mit Zuckersirup getränkt.
Und deswegen werde ich jetzt erst mal
einen Blechkuchen backen
und mache den eben mit Datteln und Walnüssen.
Und das Rezept, das entwickelt sich jetzt noch.
Also ich will jetzt einfach einen Blechkuchen machen,
was man eben auch schön auf große Menge machen kann.
Also gerade für das Ramadan-Fest dann eben,
für Ramadan Bayramı,
könnt ihr es dann zubereiten,
habt was für viele Gäste
und habt aber eben trotzdem wenig Arbeit damit.
Also es ist wirklich nicht so aufwendig wie ein Baklava.
Ich mache jetzt erst mal den Kuchen.
Später kommt noch eine Creme drauf und eine Deko.
Das überlege ich mir dann während der Herstellung.
Das entwickelt sich jetzt, wie gesagt, einfach.
Und ja, dann schauen wir einfach, was dabei rauskommt.
Also dafür verwende ich
vier Eier, – die sind bereits zimmerwarm –
100 Gramm Zucker,
200 Gramm Ayran,
200 Gramm Sonnenblumenöl,
300 Gramm Mehl,
zwei Teelöffel Backpulver und zwei Teelöffel Zimt,
und jeweils 150 Gramm Walnüsse und entsteinte Datteln.
Bei den Datteln ist wirklich ganz wichtig,
zuerst entsteinen und dann abwiegen.
Und da habe ich jetzt zwei verschiedene.
Und zwar hatte ich hier noch meine Bio-Datteln.
Die habe ich im Supermarkt bekommen, vakuumiert.
Die sind schon entsteint.
Und dann habe ich hier noch
– und das sind meine Lieblingsdatteln –
vom türkischen Supermarkt
– da bekommt ihr sie oft oder im arabischen Supermarkt.
Das sind einfach so richtig große, fleischige Datteln.
Und die sind echt supermegalecker!
Und vor allem
riesengroß.
Und ihr seht, hier drinnen richtig schön süß eben auch.
Und die habe ich jetzt kurz selber entsteint.
Also die habe ich.
Ich habe auch relativ wenig Zucker wirklich genommen
für die große Menge.
Und ich nehme hier heute Ayran.
Wenn ihr keinen Ayran bekommt,
– Ayran ist so ein salziges Getränk, ein Joghurtgetränk –
dann könnt ihr auch einfach
etwas verflüssigten Joghurt nehmen,
ihr könnt Buttermilch nehmen.
Aber dann gebt ihr einfach noch eine Prise Salz dazu.
Ayran ist einfach schon ein salziges Getränk.
Deswegen passt es jetzt hier wirklich perfekt!
Okay. Dann starte ich jetzt hier direkt.
Ihr könnt ein Handrührgerät nehmen
oder eine Küchenmaschine mit Schneebesen.
Dann kann ich jetzt zuerst mal
die Eier hier in die Rührschüssel geben
gemeinsam mit dem Zucker.
Und jetzt wirklich einfach schön cremig rühren.
Und in der Zwischenzeit kann ich hier schon mal
die trockenen Zutaten vermischen,
das heißt Mehl mit Backpulver und Zimt.
[Musik]
Das wird gleich verrührt.
Und dann werde ich auch gleich die Walnüsse mahlen
und die Datteln zerkleinern.
Das mache ich dann einfach im Mixer.
[Musik]
Ich lasse die so ein bisschen leicht grob.
Und die Datteln püriere ich jetzt hier mit dem Ayran.
So geht es einfacher
und ich bekomme sie vor allem richtig schön zerkleinert.
[Musik]
So. Jetzt ist alles richtig schön zerkleinert.
Guckt mal.
Mmh, ein Ayran-Dattel-Püree!
Dann kommt hier jetzt das Öl rein mit zur Eiermasse.
Die Dattelmasse.
[Musik]
Die Walnüsse, die habe ich jetzt wirklich
nur ganz grob zerkleinert.
So hat man gleich noch ein bisschen Biss.
Und hier das Mehl.
Wenn es etwas klumpig ist, dann bitte sieben.
Bei mir ist es wirklich superfein.
Ich verwende auch meist ein Instantmehl zum Backen,
gerade bei Rührteigen, bei Biskuit,
bei Hefeteig. Bei Mürbeteig nicht.
So. Das kommt jetzt hier alles rein.
Und jetzt wirklich nur noch ganz kurz vermischen,
bis sich alles verbunden hat.
Und dann ist der Teig schon fertig.
[Musik]
Jetzt habe ich hier den Backrahmen
schön auf Blechgröße ausgezogen.
Da kommt die Masse jetzt hinein.
Die sieht und riecht jetzt schon
richtig gut aus!
Also sieht gut aus und riecht gut.
Ich habe es ja bisher noch nicht probiert.
Also ich weiß nicht, wie es schmeckt,
aber ich denke, nicht zu süß.
So eine schöne leichte Süße durch die Datteln, wenig Zucker.
Der Ayran noch mit dabei.
[Musik]
So. Jetzt ist alles schön glatt gestrichen.
Der Kuchen kommt in den Ofen.
Und ich mache mir Gedanken
über den weiteren Verlauf des Kuchens.
[Musik]
Der Kuchen ist schon gebacken.
Ich habe ihn jetzt auch kühl gestellt,
also der war schon abgekühlt,
aber jetzt noch mal in den Kühlschrank,
damit er richtig kalt wird.
Hier mache ich jetzt schon mal die Masse,
die ich oben darauf bröseln möchte,
also nach der Creme.
Ich habe hier jetzt 200 Gramm Walnüsse.
Die sind von meiner Schwiegermama aus der Türkei.
Hat sie alle extra für uns gesammelt,
geschält und dann mitgebracht.
Echt voll süß!
Und wir haben die einfach einvakuumiert.
So halten sie nämlich länger.
100 Gramm Butter,
150 Gramm Zucker
und 200 Gramm Engelshaar.
Das bekommt ihr im türkischen oder arabischen Supermarkt.
Aus Engelshaar macht man ganz gerne Desserts.
Das ist einfach eine Teigware.
Und die ist wirklich super!
Vor allem, weil sie gleich in Kombination
mit der Butter und dem Zucker schön knusprig wird,
also so ein bisschen karamellisiert.
Die Walnüsse zerkleinere ich jetzt grob.
Deswegen mache ich das auch hier mit einem Messer.
[Musik]
Also wirklich schön grob zerkleinert.
Jetzt kommen die hier in eine Pfanne.
Wählt die Pfanne bitte groß genug aus.
Denn es kommen gleich alle Zutaten rein.
Die kann ich hier jetzt schon mal anmachen
und etwas rösten lassen
auf mittelhoher Hitze.
Und jetzt nehme ich noch das Engelshaar
und schneide das auch klein.
[Musik]
Hier gebe ich jetzt die Butter dazu.
Ist noch nicht so ganz warm.
Ah, doch,
am Pfannenboden.
Den Zucker gebe ich auch dazu.
Der darf nämlich auch gleich mitkaramellisieren.
Also jetzt einfach hier die Butter-Zucker-Nuss-Mischung
ein bisschen verrühren,
bis es leicht karamellisiert.
Das riecht jetzt schon lecker!
[Musik]
Das jetzt hier schön ein bisschen rösten lassen,
karamellisieren lassen.
Den Duft genießen!
Denn es riecht wirklich superlecker!
Ich glaube, ich muss es noch abrunden
mit etwas Zimt.
Wir ergänzen in der Zutatenliste:
einen viertel Teelöffel Zimt.
Ja!
Ach, was soll der Geiz?
Wir machen einen halben.
Oh! Es riecht einfach gerade wie gebrannte Mandeln.
Gebrannte Walnüsse.
Okay.
Jetzt das Engelshaar nicht vergessen!
Das kommt jetzt hier mit dazu.
Wie gesagt, wählt eine Pfanne, die groß genug ist.
Ich habe sie wieder zu klein gewählt.
Da ist die eine Zuschauerin,
die jedes Mal das darunterschreibt.
Ach, ich lerne es halt nie.
Ich denke mir jedes Mal so:
Oh, die große Pfanne, wer will das jetzt spülen?
Ja.
Hört ihr das, wie schön das karamellisiert?
Wie schön es knusprig anbrät?
[Musik]
So sieht die Masse jetzt aus,
schön karamellisiert.
Und ich gebe sie jetzt hier einfach auf eine Folie
zum Abkühlen.
Ihr könnt das Ganze auch,
wenn ihr es vermischt habt im Topf
und jetzt nicht so lange am Herd stehen wollt,
im Backofen karamellisieren,
einfach auch so auf einem Backblech
mit Backfolie oder Backpapier.
Aber aufpassen, dass es nicht verbrennt!
Das lasse ich jetzt schön abkühlen
und kann in der Zwischenzeit
schon mal die Sahnecreme machen.
Schön!
Die Creme könnt ihr jetzt mit Quark machen,
mit Frischkäse.
Ich nehme jetzt Schmand,
weil ich Schmand einfach auch superlecker finde.
Also einfach eins zu eins ersetzen,
wenn ihr jetzt keinen Schmand habt
oder nicht mögt.
Ich nehme dafür jetzt
400 Gramm Sahne,
400 Gramm Schmand,
etwas Vanilleextrakt
und San-apart zum Steifschlagen.
Also wirklich keinen Puderzucker.
San-apart ist ja auch schon leicht gesüßt.
Und dann habe ich wirklich nur eine leicht gesüßte Creme,
habe den Boden
und die Deko oben drauf.
Und ich denke, das reicht auf jeden Fall von der Süße.
Ich nehme jetzt die Sahne.
Die kommt in die Rührschüssel.
Wenn ihr Frischkäse, Mascarpone oder Quark nehmt,
dann verrührt ihr jetzt zuerst einmal die Zutat.
Denn die sind meist einfach etwas fester.
Schmand ist ja relativ
fein und flüssig,
also nicht flüssig, aber halt einfach geschmeidig.
Den brauche ich jetzt nicht geschmeidig rühren,
aber alles andere schon
und dann erst die Sahne dazu geben.
Dann Vanilleextrakt.
Das ist halt das Schöne an meinem Vanilleextrakt,
der ist wirklich aus der puren Vanilleschote gewonnen
und einfach mit etwas Zucker haltbar gemacht.
Und da ist deswegen kein Alkohol drin
und wird aber auch nicht schlecht.
Man hat wirklich das schöne Vanillearoma
beziehungsweise sogar Vanillekonzentrat
und,
ja, nichts Künstliches mit dabei.
Jetzt kann ich hier alles kurz verrühren.
San-apart fühle ich immer um,
habe es hier drin
und dann kann ich es jetzt einfach mit dazu geben.
[Musik]
Jetzt kann ich hier die Creme
schön auf den kalten Tortenboden streichen.
Da immer schön darauf achten,
dass der Tortenboden auch wirklich kalt ist.
Ansonsten schmilzt euch nämlich die Creme weg.
In so traditionellen Ramadan-Desserts
werden oft nicht so viele Früchte verwendet
oder gar keine frischen Früchte,
weil die sich wirklich, wenn man sie zubereitet,
über mehrere Tage halten,
auch Baklava zum Beispiel oder Tulumba tatlısı.
Alles, was so mit Zuckersirup getränkt ist,
hält sich natürlich auch.
Und
das heißt, man kann es immer einmal gut vorbereiten
und dann eben fertigstellen
und hat es dann einfach schon da.
Hier nehme ich jetzt auch keine frischen Früchte,
weil das Dessert sich jetzt auch wirklich
schon so drei, vier Tage hält.
Also es würde sich länger halten,
wenn ich jetzt keine frische Sahne
und keinen Schmand dazu verwenden würde.
Aber das macht natürlich den Kuchen extrem lecker!
Hoffe ich zumindest.
Probiert habe ich es ja noch nicht.
[Musik]
Okay, so perfekt muss man es nicht machen.
Aber es beruhigt.
Okay.
Und da kommt jetzt die Masse drauf.
Josh, hast du die schon probiert?
>> JOSH: Nein.
Darf ich?
>> SALLY: O mein Gott!
Nicht zu süß, knusprig,
crunchy,
Oberkracher!
Und das kommt jetzt hier einfach obendrauf.
[Musik]
Ach, ist das schön!
Ja.
So schnell und einfach!
Jetzt überlege ich mir noch,
ob ich was als Deko zubereite.
Jedenfalls kommt der Kuchen, also diese Schnitte,
solange in den Kühlschrank.
Und
ich überlege mir was.
Aber so wäre er schon perfekt!
Aber ich glaube, so eine...
So eine Dattel, so eine Schokodattel obendrauf,
das rundet, glaube ich, das Dessert ab.
Jetzt ist der Kuchen durchgekühlt
und ich kann ihn rauslösen.
Dafür nehme ich einen Tortenretter
und ziehe den kompletten Kuchen
– woah, der ist schwer –
hier herunter.
Damit ich gleich nicht auf meiner Backfolie schneide,
löse ich die Backfolie jetzt weg.
Also einfach umschlagen
und darunter wegziehen.
Dann den Rahmen lösen.
Ta-daa!
Ich glaube, ich schneide es...
Ich weiß noch nicht,
ob ich es in Dreiecke schneide.
Denn ich habe jetzt gesehen...
Eigentlich wollte ich ja
selber Datteln mit Schokolade überziehen.
Dann ist mir aber eingefallen,
wir haben immer mit Schokolade überzogene Datteln.
Leider gerade nur noch weiße,
da der Murat alle anderen aufgegessen hat.
Und hier haben wir sogar noch Pralinen.
Die sind mit dunkler Schokolade.
Ta-daa!
Das sind auch Datteln.
Ich glaube, ich nehme tatsächlich jetzt einfach die
zum Dekorieren.
Okay.
Wie mache ich es jetzt?
Ich glaube, ich schneide
Quadrate.
[Musik]
Ich nehme jetzt hier diese wunderschönen Pralinen
und dekoriere sie hier noch so drauf.
Murat, willst du probieren?
>> MURAT: Ja.
Unbedingt!
Es ist ja nicht so, dass ich nichts im Garten zu tun habe.
Ja.
Ich habe gerade...
>> SALLY: Ich weiß, dass du nichts zu tun hast.
Deswegen habe ich dich ja gerufen.
>> MURAT: Ja. Ich bin gerade dabei,
die Fassade zu streichen.
Nur so nebenher.
Ja.
>> SALLY: Schwöre!
>> MURAT: Ja.
Und ich weiß nicht, wo dein Vater die Leiter hingetan hat.
Ja.
>> SALLY: Da steht sie doch.
Du siehst aber nicht gerade aus,
>> SALLY: als hättest du die Fassade gestrichen.
>> MURAT: Ah, ja?
>> MURAT: Doch! Ich streiche gerade die Fassade.
Ich hatte einen Ganzkörperanzug an.
>> SALLY: Ach so.
>> MURAT: Ja. Okay, alles klar.
>> SALLY: Kannst du dir noch eine Gabel kurz holen?
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Er lügt.
>> MURAT: Okay.
Sieht aus nach Sauerkraut.
Ja.
>> SALLY: Entschuldigung. Das wird mein Ramadan-Dessert.
>> MURAT: Okay.
>> SALLY: Ich richte es jetzt gleich noch schön an.
Ich bin ja hier noch nicht fertig.
Ich bin nur hier fertig.
Aber dadurch, dass du diese dunklen alle aufgegessen hast
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: und die hellen jetzt optisch nicht so gut passen...
>> SALLY: Das sind übrigens so...
>> MURAT: Okay.
Dann probiere ich jetzt oder?
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Okay.
>> SALLY: Warum hast du eine Gabel,
>> MURAT: Mmh!
wenn du das eh mit der Hand isst?
>> MURAT: Weil du musst immer
anheben
und dann hochheben.
>> SALLY: Ich dekoriere solange weiter.
>> MURAT: Cool!
>> MURAT: Ich bin überrascht!
>> SALLY: Wow!
>> MURAT: Und zwar Folgendes:
Warum überrascht?
Wenn man so orientalische Spezialitäten macht,
>> SALLY: Ich weiß, was er sagt.
>> MURAT: dann sind sie meist zu süß.
Da...
Ich weiß nicht.
Da flippen sie alle im Orient aus
mit dem Süßen.
>> SALLY: Die denken sich halt: "Hey, wir fasten.
Und dann komm, gönne ich mir."
>> MURAT: Genau.
>> MURAT: Das ist zwar süß, aber nicht so arg,
dass ich sage: "Woah, ich kriege nur ein Stück runter!"
>> SALLY: Okay.
>> MURAT: Okay.
Schmeckt echt super!
Hat mich gewundert.
>> SALLY: Ist gut?
Hat mich gewundert?!
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: Das ist voll das schöne Ramadan-Rezept!
>> MURAT: Ist das Walnuss drauf?
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Ah, cool!
>> SALLY: Walnüsse von meiner Schwiegermama
aus der Türkei, aus Sinop!
>> MURAT: Ja!
>> SALLY: Hat sie für uns extra geschält und mitgebracht
und ich habe sie vakuumiert.
>> MURAT: Hm.
Kann ich die Leiter mitnehmen?
>> MURAT: Brauchst du die in der Küche?
>> SALLY: Kannst du mitnehmen.
>> SALLY: Nein.
Nimm sie einfach mit, okay?
>> MURAT: Jeder braucht mal eine Leiter!
>> SALLY: Und ihr könnt das Rezept gerne nachbacken.
Wenn ihr kein so großes Blech backen wollt,
>> MURAT: Mmh!
>> SALLY: dann könnt ihr einfach in meiner App
die Zutaten herunterrechnen
auf eure Backformgröße.
Ihr könnt das Ganze auch rund backen zum Beispiel.
Gebt dann einfach eine runde Backform an mit
20, 22, 26 cm.
>> MURAT: Ja, mich hat sie ja auch schon rundgebacken.
Ja.
Macht sie gerne.
Sally
tut gerne Dinge rundbacken.
Backt euren Mann auch rund!
Aber das ist in eurer Familie.
>> SALLY: Ach, Murat!
>> MURAT: Sie ist schön rechteckig, hoch.
>> SALLY: Rechteckig?!
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Was willst du denn jetzt damit sagen?
Also macht es gut!
Macht es besser!
Haltet euren Mann bei Laune
und backt ihn einfach rund!
Bis zum nächsten Mal!
Tschüss!
>> MURAT: Tschüss!
>> SALLY: Pass auf, dass du die Scheiben nicht einschlägst!
Achtung, Kurve!
Okay.
Tschüss!
[Musik]